[Music]
It
started out as a sphere.It's
not just a
class.It reflects all kinds of things and
can
change.I decided to throw it to this place and
observe.
When it got
warmer, I took a picture of the scene
Before long, even if courage began to descend on this land, the
hair that chased
after each other was [music] from Minamibo, and I was
exhausted
[music]
[Music]
And then I got the animal I
didn't know how to
walk I can't reproduce it right away The
movement is erotic It
seems to have duplicated the wound
[Music] When I
started walking,
I felt the coldness of the wind for the first time.
I don't have one, so it's impossible for you to skate about me You're
more quiet than usual I
'm sorry, I'm
tired
[Music]
There are so many things I don't know
I realized that my body temperature is rising
[Music] I
wonder if I'm in arrears
Attractive space If you can talk, you've been here for a long
time, so you always say you can't get close to another one,
right?
It's not attractive
But it can't be helped The
last one died a year ago
Sarah The fire
goes out Can I say it before it goes out
[Music]
That boy whose name I don't know
That was the
first  I was alone
[music] It's been
snowing and it hasn't dried out at all
Grandma's tree is
useless I don't even want to borrow it from the first day
It's been 5 years since everyone left It's been 5 years since everyone left
That moko has been there forever
[music]
There are a lot of people and food, believe
[Music] It
's like a paradise, they say.
There are people out there who are much smarter than us, and
they live happily every day
.  I
was bitten by a bridge, so I
took care of the old ladies
and became
a boothman.
] In the
end, the only ones left here were the old
women I couldn't help and
[music]
Hey
Welcome back,
Nah, fish
.  Namo cat,
what's your favorite food
? Did you forget how to eat it?
This is the lady next door
, right?
I
'm sure there will be bad things, but
I still
want to know the world
Machilau
You are with me
I'm going straight south with my house behind me I
can't see it now,
but someday a mountain will appear like a big wall
Beyond it is
paradise We'll keep going until it
gets
dark  Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha,
this is a message.
I know about vegetables I
heard they ate them a long time ago, but I don't remember them at all
Other round, sweet fruits
I asked my uncle what it felt like to be heavy,
but I didn't really understand
I want to eat it, it's
exciting
.
[music] um [music] It's
snowing
now It's Yowane Car The
journey has only just begun
[music]  ]
Look at me, I'm
approaching Mt. Oiso and it's a game.
It
's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's
just a scratch,
it's
just a
scratch  The day after tomorrow, even if you say you don't like
it, I'll still walk
I'll use my physical strength while it's still
[music]
This is different I
don't know if everyone is still alive so I'll
stop moving forward
I think I'm even more stupid if I
go home like this I'll just talk with that house
I don't want
to go to the same place as everyone
This is the only thing I want to do anymore
Besides
I'm sure the place won't come back because the place is
attractive Attractive food Attractive people
That's really fun, I'm happy and I'm too happy
That's why
[music]
me
[music
]  It's a trace
You can pull
it out It means everyone was here
So
there's no doubt that we can go to the mountains like this We can definitely go
[music]
I can go I'm scared I can go
There's
no way you can say something to me
Aye,
that's right
Nande
What was it in your head
[music]
f 6 eme
no no no no no no no no no
[music]
rice
You're here, I'm not coming I'm not coming I'm
not coming
[music] I
'm
overworked I can
distribute
[music]
I decided
that
I want to go home It's not you I
understand
[music] dea [music]
What is that face
[music]
Is love bad,
but you're trying to make me laugh?
Healing and healing  Yon Bach Well, my
mother smells like
that.
Ten
Horror When everyone comes home,
there won't be a net,
right?
[music]
voodoo
[music] [music] um [music]
yeah yeah yeah
[music] [music]
huh
[music]
[applause]
I'm gonna get 1 with this I'm
precious
Wing bow
Arson wait for me  You gave me
Ah, I'm not alone now I can do my best
3 day Mina
There are
people Nice to meet you all today
What kind of place is this?
It's a security stimulus to acquire a human figure
That's why I started walking in search of further stimulus
From now
on, I'll meet various people and feel various things I
wanted to imagine a boy Ah me
ani
ane
[music]
m
me
[music] hmm [music]
you
too
goo ah ah ah ah
good no
-2
me
I'm good
conoha
's
[music]
tano ah ah ah meni
me
nanairo
[music]
me
wh
that's it  We arrived at the first place in the
forest.Matchi, a young girl growing up in the backyard.However, according to
the customs of the village, she was chosen as one of the 22
and wanted to become an adult.